out of the story a search is underway
for a hacker who caused panic and
confusion in Dallas by triggering all of
the city's emergency sirens at the same
time the system was hacked just before
midnight Friday all 156 sirens in Dallas
blared intermittently for more than an
hour and a half the 911 center was
flooded with more than 4,400 calls from
concerned residents the sirens are
intended to warn people of incoming
severe weather
city officials said the hack originated
in the Dallas area and they are working
with the Federal Communications
Commission to look for a suspect CBS
News contributor Nicholas Thompson is
editor in chief of Wired Nick good
morning morning Erin how could something
like this happen well we don't know
exactly they haven't said exactly how it
was hacked but there is an interesting
trade-off which does explain it which is
that when you have a system like an
emergency warning system you want it to
be pretty easy to operate operate in a
tough situation which means you make it
pretty simple to set off so it also is
something that's relatively simple to
hack what I think probably happened is
they are activated by radio
transmissions most likely and probably
somebody figured out the frequency with
which they're operated and figured out
whatever encryption they use in Dallas
and then set them off for whatever
reason and what would be their
motivation well one hypothesis is that
it's just a kid doing a stunt another
motivation is it's a disgruntled city
employee trying to show how weak the
system is the most nefarious explanation
would be it's somebody trying to cover
up something else you set up all the
emergency sirens you Jam 9-1-1 you can
do whatever you wanted to see how
vulnerable are our municipal
infrastructure is overall to this kind
of hacking I think quite vulnerable and
the reason is that you don't suspect
someone is going to do it right you run
a bank you know people are going to try
to steal the money so you set up a lot
of protections you have a bunch of
tornado warning sirens you're not going
to think that somebody's going to go oh
let's set off the tornado warning siren
system because there's no reason to so
you don't really build up the defenses
you don't train the defenses and then
something like this so how do you
upgrade the security around this kind of
infrastructure well you have to change
the encryption right so if it is a radio
signal again we don't know that that's
not confirmed but the fact that the FCC
isn't
so getting kind of suggests that is so
what you do is you have a better
encryption key right so some signal is
sent to the towers to set it off
presumably you have some kind of
encryption set to the time you have some
kind of special password or something
maybe you set up another layer so it's a
little harder to crack into what it is
well it's a sign of the times and too
many people can act too many things
right exactly that this is something we
are going to see a lot more of we've
seen lots of attempts to try to hack it
what is so interesting here is they said
it was somebody in Dallas it was not
somebody remote so it wasn't somebody
sitting in another country it wasn't
somebody sitting in New York saying
let's set off the Dallas systems it's
somebody in Dallas they have confirmed
that they do know that so that's suggest
it's not sort of remote entry computer
problem which is what we keep seeing so
frequently sowing chaos [ __ ] always
good to see you thanks as always thank
you I wasn't sowing chaos here no no you
are not we're speaking of the different